alors pour évoquer ton adolescence en
france et j'ai de faire une petite
interview première fois bon c'est prêt
oui première vous première boum avec ça
je me rappelle toutes les boomers
toujours pareil il m'a invité pour faire
rire
la première partie de soirée puis dit
laisse loire isère me demandait de
rester près du bûcher jeudi dernier en
moi c'est une fille première idole
première idole au boeuf commence à se
savoir jeudi que j'aime vraiment bien
que claude françois
tu voulais toutes ses chansons par coeur
a pas mal pas mal me suis pas fétichiste
on m'avait dit ça j'ai acheté un costume
de bio aux enchères est ce que tu sais
qui a écrit les lundis au soleil
ouais fait qu'il y ait un copain
s'appelle pas trébucher bravant premiers
pleurs premiers flirts sellers en
autocar dans le fond avec à la plus
belle en direction de l'italie
j'ai dit j'ai dit le dernier de la
classe de vidéos surfer il est à l'avant
je l'avais de macase sorti avec une
fille ouais je sais bien passé quand
même bien j'ai pensé qu'on veut parce
qu'il ya être finement
première cuite la dernière salle entière
alors la forêt me taire je pense juste
votre en boutre au lycée ouais tu vas
pas particulièrement
non non non non je te bourrer du premier
vrai amour premier vrai amour ce doit
être un art mural robin je vous que je
suis maman tombait bien d'un modèle
première expérience sexuelle
ah bah oui on m'a dit moi il fallait
absolument merde j'avais 19 ans fait
absolument que je suis passé à l'acte à
l'acte et je me suis renseigné sur la
fille est plus facile du lycée et qui a
tout s'est passé comme une lettre à la
poste
1er juin en mai juin c'était selon temps
à la police est bon il n'ya pas
longtemps
non au collège au collège du collège ont
soutenus j'étais vraiment on était fous
comme n'importe quoi on fumait du café
du thé premier procès j'en ai pas encore
eu au nom il ya non non j'ai voulu en
faire un point sur un cône à paul wermus
l'anis qu'est ce qui t'a les grands
reporters des salons de thé
mais qu'il avait dit vous le rappelle
rappelons le vient pas le magnéto qu'un
pâle imitateur de sylvie joly
donc ça m'avait énervé quoi qui le dit
qui le dévoile tout premier guide
premier dit de ce soir je dis moi alors
tu vas tout ça c'était pour t'amener
pour remuer des souvenirs d'enfance et
d'adolescence je suis très ébranlée bah
oui ça est ce que tu as fait longtemps
pipi au lit
bon puisque l'ancien ta mère tu en
parles par la succion là quelque chose
qui a marqué dans la famille non plus
maintenant il ya un truc quoi voir le
pipi au lit
moi c'est vraiment fini et je suis
vraiment content regarde on va voir j'ai
plus rien une fois l'année dernière